[Music]
this episode is brought to you by four
Sigma deck
you might remember four sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys I would love to
experiment with this and maybe actually
suggest it but I'd like a version
without sweeteners if you'd be open to
it if too much of headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
and or nutmilk such as almond milk &
quot so I'm gonna say no you should suck
it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
she take the advice of all Chinese
people when they're criticizing young
uns when they say boo and I'm sure
they're cool which means you're not able
to eat bitterness bitter is in many
cases an indication of things that help
liver detoxification and so on not
saying that's the case here but I've
tested this ratio lecture on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and no don't put it in honey or nut milk
or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like puer that kind of stuff that
type of tea you're gonna dig it so just
try it okay back to then my read if
you'd like to naturally improve your
sleep both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic
fueled mint extract organic rosehips
extract organic Tulsi extract and that's
it
no fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit
anything so check it out go to four
sigma tech comm forward slash ferrous
and get 20% off this special batch I
don't know if they're gonna be making
much more of this since it was made
specifically for you guys so do me a
favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI GMA TI c-calm /e
ferrous f e RR ISS and get 20% off the
special batch and you must use the code
Faris to receive your discount fer our
ISS so again go to 4 Sigma 2 comm
forward slash ferrous and then use code
ferrous for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens every year of course
people look for new ways to become
healthier to take their fitness and so
on to the next level for me step number
one is having some form of nutritional
insurance that's how I would look at it
and the nutritional insurance needs to
make sure all of my basic needs are met
all the boxes checked regardless of
travel schedule missed meals and so on
there going to be times in the new year
when your diet and exercise will get
interrupted life will interrupt it then
during those times you want a safety net
I get asked all the time if you could
only use one supplement what would it be
and my answer is inevitably athletic
greens it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive 30% off of
your first order by visiting athletic
greens comm forward slash to him that is
a great deal on one of my favorite
products and it covers my basics each
day it is part of my routine and it
leaves me with less to worry about if
for instance I have to skip a meal or
just can't get a high quality meal so
check it out go to athletic greens comm
forward slash Tim and learn all about it
hello ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls and welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is always
my job each and every episode to
interview world-class performers and
experts leaders in all fields and that
ranges from amazing athletes to military
personnel to chess prodigies to famous
investors and beyond in this episode
we're going to set a new podcast record
for this show at least with five
different guests these are people that I
have interviewed remotely and this
episode today features Adam Robinson
Debbie Millman Neil Strauss Scott Belsky
and Veronica Belmont these are all
people who are I consider the best at
what they do or at least
one of the best in the world at the many
things that they do and that of course
includes investing chess graphic design
writing tech and much much more this
particular round table discussion covers
topics posed to all of them questions
posed to all in them including best
investments what are the best
investments they've ever made what are
their favorite failures in other words
failures that have led to later
successes and bad recommendations in
their areas of expertise that you should
avoid this is a composite episode which
many of you have requested explicitly
because you want to be able to see the
patterns and the each guest offers a lot
of actionable life advice so that
further ado please give a listen and I
hope you enjoy this as much as I did our
guest today is Adam Robinson you can
find him on Twitter at I am Adam
Robinson or at Robinson global
strategies comm Adam has made a lifelong
study of outflanking and outsmarting the
competition he is rated chess master and
has been awarded a life master title by
the United States Chess Federation as a
teenager he was personally mentored by
Bobby Fischer in the 18 months leading
up to his winning the World Championship
and Adam and I talked a lot about this
in our first conversation on the Tim
Ferriss show which you guys can check
out but back to the bio then in Adam's
first career he developed a
revolutionary approach to taking
standardized tests as one of the two
original cofounders of the Princeton
Review his paradigm breaking or category
killing as they say in publishing test
prep book cracking the system the SAT is
the only test prep book to have ever
become a New York Times bestseller after
selling his interest in the Princeton
Review Adam turned his attention in the
early 90s to the then emerging field of
artificial intelligence developing a
program that could analyze text and
provide human-like commentary he was
later invited to join a well-known quant
fund to develop statistical trading
models and since he has established
himself as an independent global macro
advisor to the chief investment
officer's of a select group of the
world's most successful hedge funds and
ultra high-net-worth family offices
what are bad recommendations that you
hear in your profession or area of
expertise my field was that of global
finance and virtually all investors have
been told when they were younger were
implicitly believed or have been tacitly
encouraged to do so by the cookie cutter
curriculums of business schools they all
attend that the more they understand the
world the better their investment
results it makes sense doesn't it the
more information we acquire and evaluate
the air quotes better informed we become
and the better our decisions
accumulating information becoming better
informed is certainly an advantage in
numerous if not most fields but not in
the counterintuitive world of investing
we're accumulating information can
actually hurt your investment results so
in 1974 Paul slovic a world-class
psychologist and a peer of Nobel
laureate Daniel Kahneman decided to
evaluate the effect of information on
decision making this study should be
taught at every Business School in the
country
Slavik gathered eight professional horse
handicappers and announced to them I
want to see how well you predict the
winners of horse races now these
handicappers were all seasoned
professionals who made their living
solely on their gambling skills slovak
told them the test would consist of
predicting 40 horse races in four
consecutive rounds in the first round
each gambler would be given the five
pieces of information he wanted on each
horse which would vary from handicapper
to handicapper 1 handicapper for example
might want the years of experience that
jockey has had as one of his top five
variables while another might not care
at all about that but want the fastest
speed for any given horse it achieved in
the past year or the weight of the
jockey or whatever finally in addition
to asking the handicappers to predict
the winner of each race he asked each
one to also state how confident he was
in his prediction now as it turns out
there were an average of 10 horses in
each race so we would expect by blind
chance random guessing that each
handicapper would be right 10% of the
time that their confidence with a blind
guest to be 10%
so in round one let's see how they did
with just five pieces of information the
handicappers were 17% accurate which is
pretty good actually
70% better than the 10% chance they
started with given zero pieces of
information and interestingly their
confidence was 19% almost exactly as
confident as they should have been
they were 17% accurate and 19% confident
in their predictions excellent
calibration in round 2 they were then
given ten pieces of information in round
three 20 and in the fourth and final
round each handicapper was given 40
pieces of information that's a whole lot
more statistics than the five pieces of
information
they each started with surprisingly
their accuracy had flatlined at 17% they
were no more accurate with the
additional 35 pieces of information they
had unfortunately their confidence in
their predictions had nearly doubled to
31 percent so the additional information
made them no more accurate but a whole
lot more confident which would have led
them to increase the size of their bets
and lose money as a result beyond a
certain amount of information a certain
minimal amount additional information
only feeds confirmation bias leaving
aside the considerable cost and delay
occasioned in acquiring that information
the additional information we gain that
conflicts with our original assessment
or conclusion we conveniently ignore or
dismiss while the information that
confirms our original decision makes us
increasingly certain that our conclusion
was correct so to return to investing
the second problem with trying to
understand the world is that it is
simply far too complex to grasp and the
more dog at our attempts to understand
the world the more earnestly we want to
explain its air quotes explain events
and trans in it the more we become
attached to our resulting beliefs which
are almost always more or less mistaken
blinding us to the financial trends that
are actually unfolding right in front of
our eyes worse we think we understand
the world giving us a false sense of
confidence
when in fact we are almost always more
or less mistaken you hear all the time
from even the most seasoned investors in
financial expert that this trend or that
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
the dollar keeps going lower or it makes
no sense that stocks keep going higher
but what's really going on when
investors say that something makes no
sense is that they have a dozen or
whatever reasons why the trend should be
moving in the opposite direction yet it
keeps moving in the current direction so
they believe the trend air quotes makes
no sense but what makes no sense is
their model of the world
that's what doesn't make sense the world
always makes sense we just don't
understand it in fact because financial
trends involve human behavior and human
beliefs on a global scale the most
powerful trends won't make sense until
it becomes too late to profit from them
by the time investors formulate an
understanding again a false
understanding that gives them the
feeling of confidence to invest the
investment opportunity has likely
already passed so when I hear
sophisticated investors or financial
commentators say for example that it
makes no sense how energy stocks keep
going lower I know that energy stocks
have a lot lower to go because all those
investors are on the wrong side of the
trade in denial
probably doubling down on their original
decision to buy energy stocks eventually
they'll be forced to throw in the towel
and have to sell those energy stocks
driving prices still lower what is one
of the best or most worthwhile
investments you've ever made I've made
many investments in my life money of
time of energy of passion and emotion
and one of the best payoffs for the
amount invested was learning to meditate
I've always been driven excited by the
world so my mind is continually racing
at a thousand miles per hour pursuing
this question or that creating this
system or that non-stop 24 hours a day
365 days a year
366 on leap years now all that non-stop
mental and psychic stimulation gets
exhausting of course and if you want to
perform optimally at anything you need
to find a way to recover
from the stresses of that activity so I
knew that though I should find a way to
turn off my mind and air quotes just
relax just enjoy just be for years I had
failed to find a way I tried everything
yoga exercise I even tried hypnosis I
researched once the best hypnotist in
New York City as a way to somehow turn
off my hyperactive mind but after for
attempted and hugely expensive sessions
with this guy the hypnotist gave up
saying your mind is too active to submit
to the hypnosis well thanks a lot doc I
told I'm not concealing my annoyance
that's exactly why I had come to him
then about two years ago my bestie Josh
Waitzkin recognizing that I couldn't
unwind or disengage from my relentless
analyzing the world especially the
financial world recommended that I take
up meditation sorry I said it doesn't
work for me I can't sit still long
enough for any benefits of meditating to
kick in so he asked have you ever tried
heart rate variability training HRV
training and I said no what's that he
said that you just focused on your
breathing using biofeedback to measure
the smoothness and the amplitude hence
the word variability of your heart rate
the heart not surprisingly registers all
our real-time emotions and stresses so
the normal heartbeat is highly erratic
staying within a tight band around an
average the goal with the biofeedback
training is to gain control over your
own heart rate by focusing on your
breathing
making your jagat heart rate smooth out
like a sine curve and to widen its
amplitude that sounded interesting but
it wasn't until I reframed meditation
that I submitted to trying it the
problem with meditation I thought was
that it wasn't practical and worse the
time I spent meditating was time I could
have spent analyzing the world but I
eventually reframed meditation as a way
to relinquish control of my conscious
mind so that my more powerful
unconscious mind could take over and my
analysis of
the world would improve motivated by
that reframing I enthusiastically
adopted biofeedback HRV training and in
a few weeks learned to quiet my mind
after just a single deep diaphragm belly
breath gaining the ability to achieve a
zen-like calm on demand now whenever I
need to detach from the world or from
the stresses of daily life and to allow
my mind a rest I simply get centered and
inhale from my diaphragm and I do so
numerous times a day a minute here a
minute there and at least once a day I
waste that's air quotes I waste a larger
15 to 20 minute block of time meditating
in this way but it's not wasted time of
course since the increased creativity
and productivity from these many
restorative sessions it's far more
valuable than the time I spend being
unproductive again air quotes while
meditating meditation is one of the most
practical powerful productivity
enhancing tools ever created and
learning to meditate is one of the best
investments I've ever made today's guest
is Debbie Millman one of my favorite
people
Debbie Millman at Debbie Millman on
Twitter and Instagram so please say
hello Debbie Millman dot-com she has
been called one of the most influential
designers working today my graphic
design USA she is the founder and host
of design matters the world's first and
longest-running podcast about design
where she's interviewed nearly 300
design luminaries and cultural
commentators including Massimo Vignelli
and Milton Glaser her artwork has been
exhibited around the world and she's
designed everything from wrapping paper
to beach towels greeting cards to
playing cards notebooks to t-shirts and
Star Wars merchandise to global Burger
King reprints she's done everything
debbie is the president emeritus of AIGA
one of only five women to hold the
position in the organization's 100-year
history the editorial and creative
director of print magazine and the
author of six books in 2009 Debbie
co-founded alongside Stephen Heller the
world's first master's program in
branding at the
School of Visual Arts in New York City
which has received international acclaim
debbie is brilliant she is one of the
sweetest humans I know and has taught me
so so much including as you will learn
Bizzy is a decision so without further
ado please enjoy the ever interesting
and insightful Debbie Millman how is a
failure or apparent failure set you up
for later success do you have a quote
favorite failure and quote of yours Oh
Tim I have so many failures I think the
first decade of my career were
experiments and failure rejection and
humiliation but I do have a favorite so
I will share that in early 2003 a good
friend sent me an email with a subject
line that read begin drinking heavily
before opening the email contained a
link to a blog titled speak up the first
ever online forum about graphic design
and branding in the world suddenly
sprawled before my eyes I found myself
reading an article that disparaged my
entire career this particular incident
in tandem with a number of historical
rejections and setbacks and humiliations
sent me into a really deep depression
and I seriously considered leaving the
design profession altogether however
however in the 14 years since this
occurred this utter takedown of
everything I'd done to date and
everything I thought was a complete and
total failure for a long long time
ultimately transformed into the
foundation of everything I've done since
everything I am doing now contains the
seeds of origin from that time so it
turns out for me the worst professional
experience
I faced ultimately became the most
important defining experience of my life
what is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made
this answer might surprise you or maybe
not but the best investment I've ever
made was in psychotherapy when I first
started I was in my early 30s
and the bills practically killed me but
I knew I needed to deeply understand all
the destructive things that had happened
to me in order to try to live a
remarkable life despite these things and
I wanted this more than anything over
the years I still sometimes smart at the
moment at the monthly invoices but I've
never doubted that this investment has
profoundly profoundly shaped who I've
become and although I still think I have
a lot of work to do it's changed and
then saved my life in every imaginable
way and I'm in what is called
psychoanalytic psychotherapy
put another way psychoanalysis with an
emphasis on self psychology and so for
me talk therapy is the only thing that
I've ever really felt drawn to things
like EMDR and behavior modification
might be really really helpful for other
people but they seem a little bit too
voodoo for me so some things that I
think are important to consider strictly
from my perspective I'm not an expert at
assessing or analyzing the value or
worth of psychoanalysis only I am able
to convey what this has done for me
but for me once a week therapy did not
work well twice or more gives you
continuity and an opportunity to
germinate in a way that once a week
doesn't also once a week almost feels
like a catch-up you sort of bring the
therapist up to speed on what happened
in the last week I think you have 20
minutes to sort of talk about what's
happening right now
therapy takes time I often say that
anything worthwhile takes a long time
and therapy is one of those things I've
been in therapy for a really long time
for decades but I can now after those
decades actually point to empirical
evidence of how my behavior in the world
my sense of who I am has fundamentally
fundamentally
changed and so being in therapy and
being a therapy for any length of time
it takes dedication it takes stamina
takes resilience persistence and a lot
of courage to face things that you might
be really afraid to look at so it's not
a quick fix but but like I said it's
really saved my life try and tell your
therapist everything if you edit who you
are or if you pretend to be something
that you're not in order to impress the
therapist if you want to project who or
how you want to be seen it will take
that much longer
so just be yourself they've likely in
their practice heard everything
they understand humanity so just be
yourself if you're afraid your therapist
will judge you tell them that also
because that whole projection is really
critical to understanding the dynamic
that you have with people in general so
all of these things are really important
to talk about there is no shame in
feeling shame and I'm saying this from a
place of deep empathy almost everyone
feels shame I think Bernie Brown says
that anybody that doesn't feel shame is
likely a pathological person so almost
everyone does in therapy will help you
understand it there is nothing like
understanding your motivations and
insecurities to help you integrate all
of those feelings in your psyche in the
most healthy and authentic way so for me
I would not recommend going to a
therapist that one of your friends goes
to asking your friends forever and then
going to somebody that they see might
seem like a good idea because that
person trusts them and therefore by
extension you might feel like you can
too but it ends up blurring things quite
a bit and I think most therapists abide
by this rule now of not seeing friends
of or clients of friends things really
do get very blurry and boundaries can
get weird and I just don't recommend
that okay big elephant in the room here
it is going to be expensive
but what is more valuable than better
understanding who you are breaking
intrinsic bad habits getting over much
of your [ __ ] or at least understanding
why you do the [ __ ] in the first place
and generally living a happier more
contented more peaceful life
one thing that I've come to understand
recently and this was actually not only
through the help of my therapist and
guidance from my therapist but also
through my dear dear friend Seth Godin
is understanding the difference between
happiness and pleasure and I think
people are often trying to reach for and
strive for pleasure and and the response
to trying to seek pleasure is actually
wanting more pleasure after that you
know we live on this hedonistic
treadmill we metabolize our purchases
and our experiences very quickly and so
when we have that pleasure or experience
that pleasure then we want more
happiness is very different happiness
essentially means you're okay as is you
don't need more you don't want more you
feel good with what you have and I think
that therapy really helps you understand
the difference between what you seek
what your motivations are and ultimately
what you want and how you can manifest
that in your life so breaking these
intrinsic bad habits getting over much
of your [ __ ] and generally living this
happier more contented more peaceful
life is something that I think is the
ultimate gift of therapy or the payoff
and and Leslie my advice to anyone
looking for a therapist is to make sure
they're really trained I highly
recommend training here a PhD and MD
plus postdoctoral training you really do
get what you pay for here and I highly
recommend somebody that is truly fully
educated in what they do
what are bad recommendations you hear in
your profession or area of expertise I
don't believe in work-life balance I
believe if you view your work as a
calling it is a labor of love rather
than laborious when your work is a
calling you are not approaching the
amount of hours you were working with
with a sense of dread or counting the
minutes until the weekend your calling
can become a life-affirming engagement
that can provide its own balance and
spiritual nourishment and ironically it
takes hard work to achieve this so when
you're in your 20s and your 30s and you
want to have a remarkable fulfilling
career you must work hard if you don't
work harder than everyone else you will
not get ahead also if you're looking for
work-life balance in your 20s or 30s
you're likely in the wrong career if
you're doing something that you love you
don't want work-life balance you want to
be able to do this thing that you love
as often as possible our guest today is
Neil Strauss you can find him on twitter
at neil strauss instagram at neil
underscore Strauss and at Neil Strauss
comm he is an 8 time New York Times
bestselling author he is a glutton for
punishment likes to write a lot of books
his books the game and rules of the game
for which he went undercover in a secret
society of pickup artists made him an
international celebrity in an accidental
hero to men around the world and his
follow-up book the truth subtitle and
uncomfortable book about relationships
Strauss dives deep into the worlds of
sex addiction non-monogamy infidelity
and intimacy and explores the hidden
forces that cause people to choose each
other stay together and break up he most
recently co-authored with Kevin Hart the
instant number one near Times bestseller
I can't make this up life lessons
how has a failure or a parent failure
set you up for later success do you have
any favorite failure of yours and it's
funny like it's such a theme right like
like those failures might hurt at the
time but I think anyone who's got
anywhere say those failures are the best
thing that ever happened to them I mean
for me and it's kind of embarrassing
because I ended up writing at the New
York Times for ten years yes I was
actually rejected from journalism school
right what's the lesson there is like if
you're rejected from something it
doesn't mean it's not right for you it
just means it wasn't right for the
person who made that decision and
especially if you're doing something new
or different and you're trying to go
somewhere it's very status quo they're
not gonna get you or accept you so it's
a powerful thing and not a lot of people
have this inner confidence to know this
is my passion and I don't need someone
to give me a green light to live in my
passion so so so I got rejected from
journalism school and I think if I got
accepted I would have followed the
regular route and like been covering
like city hall meetings and like you
know we Hawk in New Jersey or something
and no offense to anyone living in
Weehawken yeah so not getting in
journalism school was the only reason I
became a journalist wrote for the New
York Times and often right there there's
other paths to get to where you want and
sometimes you have to trust that the
path you're on is the right path in fact
you have to trust it because there's no
other path but the one you're on and the
bigger idea is this the outcome is not
the outcome and what I mean by this is
there's that as the famous I want to say
it's a Zen parable and it's and I'm
gonna totally misquote it and get it
wrong but there's a farmer and his horse
brags this brakes this horse I don't
know this horse runs away let's say hey
this horse runs away and I say that's
too bad I'm sorry your horse ran away
it's really gonna mess up your farm he's
like nah that's all right you know but
you know II don't know yet if it's for
the greater for the bad and then maybe
his horse I think this horse came back
with like four other horses and again
I'm totally massacring this parable but
that you'll get the point
his horse came back with four other
horses they're like a while that's
amazing now you have four horses how
lucky are
he's like well I don't know we'll see
then one day his son is riding the horse
one of the new horses the horse buxom
the son is thrown and he breaks his knee
like you know really badly shatters and
breaks his leg they said oh that's too
bad I'm sorry your son break your leg
broke his leg that's horrible for you
and him and now he you know can't work
on the farm and all these bad things and
the farmer says I don't know you know
we'll see I don't know if it's bad or
good then there's suddenly a war and
they go to kind of draft people into the
war and turns out the son can't go off
to fight because he's broken his leg and
his life is saved because he's broke his
leg I said oh my god thank God that
horse threw your son now he was like was
saved and the farmer says I don't know
we'll see and the point is you don't
know if something's good or bad because
if it's only one ending right then even
that ending the universe goes on your
family and your loved ones they go on to
so the outcome is not the outcome the
end is not the end we measure these
things by these end points they're not
their real end points the truth is you
don't know you'll see keep moving
forward you don't know the outcome is
not the outcome what is one of the best
or most worthwhile investments you've
ever made I would just say that for me
it was time time is obviously the most
valuable resource we have
sidenote and this is something that's
often talked about here is just people
are so careful with their money even
with getting ripped off for a dollar
three dollars five dollars yet they're
so generous with their time in fact I
shouldn't be doing this right now I've
had things to do a little exercise that
I learned from a marketer named Dan
Kennedy is there's kind of a form
whether you can do which is figure out
what you make in a year
divide it by the amount of work hours in
a year and then divide that by three
because the average person only spends
one third of each at work hour working
and that's what your time is worth so
next time you feel like an obligation to
go to lunch with someone you know add
that up and see if you really want to be
giving that person however many dollars
that is
so the point is the best invention I
made was actually investment of time
which was I was an unpaid intern at the
Village Voice and I think like the
secret and and again Robert Greene says
this in his book mastery it's something
that's often said but like being willing
to work and this goes against everything
in the culture right now in a lot of
ways but really being willing to work
for free and to be totally exploited yes
as a resource just to be the around
people who are writing around people who
are creative inside a sort of busy
newspaper newsroom that was full of you
know culture and life and to be around
artists and critics and writers I really
admired that like changed my life if I
was not an unpaid intern at the Village
Voice and got rejected from journalism
school again I wouldn't be writing and
talking to you I literally spent a year
just opening mail and doing people
expense reports waiting for the chance
just to write like once but the crazy
thing is once I wrote once no one knew I
was an intern they just thought I was a
writer for The Village Voice and that
got me really you know really far I
think I stayed there for three years
I think they it was really hard for them
to get rid of me who so so that that
that actually was my journalism school
and I only learned to write by having
great editors there so I would say like
being willing to listen to someone who
is more proficient at you than something
telling you what you're doing wrong and
internalizing that I'm not taking it
personally is huge are they always right
no but they might know more than you so
it's worth seriously considering I've
seen amazing people who are just
starting something new who let their ego
get in the way of a good lesson or
opportunity
I've sat there why maybe the greatest
surfer in the world is giving an amateur
surfer advice and the amateur surfer is
so worried that they'll be judged by the
famous guy did they try to pretend what
they like they know what they're talking
about and what they know about surfing
instead of just shutting up listening
and trying it
and here's what I here's another thing
about everybody who's great I can go off
on these questions forever but another
thing about everybody who's great is
even if they don't agree with it they're
willing to try it if it won't hurt them
or someone else so again if we talk
about certificate adjust your stance for
me with writing of a writer saying rush
off the academic dust that would like to
quote French post-modernism to like show
people I was smart or something I don't
know what I was thinking but try it
first seriously try and see if it works
before you discard it the big idea
that's gonna change your life are gonna
change your creativity is the one you
disagree with if you have the resistance
to it and you try it anyway that's where
the big breakthrough is the ones you
agree with you're already doing or
believe in so there won't be a big
breakthrough there today's guest is
Scott Belsky you can find him on Twitter
and Instagram at Scott Belsky be Els KY
and at Scott Belsky com Scott is an
entrepreneur author and investor he is a
venture partner at benchmark a very very
very highly regarded venture capital
firm based in San Francisco
Scott co-founded Behance in 2006 and
served as CEO until Adobe acquired Vance
in 2012
millions of people used bands to display
their portfolios as well as track and
find top talent across the creative
industries he is an early investor and
advisor in Pinterest uber and periscope
among many other fast growing startups
he is a friend and one of the people I
call most often for start-up and life
advice
he's crafted a very very very unique
career and life for himself so without
further ado please enjoy a few questions
with the ever so interesting and
insightful Scott Belsky
what are bad recommendations you hear in
your profession or area of expertise the
first thing that came to my mind was
that industries are led by experts
you know we idolize the experts in our
industry we often forget that industries
are often transformed by neophytes right
I mean look at you know bold
transformations like uber disrupting
transportation or Airbnb disrupting
hospitality these are all plays that
were led by outsiders remember I
remember talking to Joe Gebbia
co-founder of Airbnb who is saying that
he didn't know common hotel industry
terms when he had started Airbnb he had
no background in the business and as
such a concept that so many hotel
executives discounted as ridiculous that
the customer would never want you know
they were more open to and which begs
the question you know perhaps the
playbook the change in industry is to be
naive enough at the start to question
these basic assumptions and to stay
alive long enough to employ skills that
are unique and advantageous to the space
that you seek to change you know perhaps
this naive excitement and pragmatic
expertise are as equally important
traits but just at different times the
second bad recommendation you hear in
your profession is is that customers
know best and the only gosh I think the
only focus group I ever ran at Behance
was in the very beginning in 2007 when
we were debating a number of different
approaches towards our mission which was
to organize the creative world we
presented the focus group that we'd
gathered together with a bottle of wine
and one evening we presented to this
focus group participants five or six
different ideas and then asked them to
complete a survey because we were really
trying to triangulate you know what we
would be doing it first in our business
universally participants said that the
last thing that they wanted was quote
unquote yet another social network to
connect with creative peers they figured
that myspace was sufficient for this
purpose but when they were asked by us
about their greatest struggles
participants talked about you know the
expense and efficiencies and
containing an online portfolio and how
difficult it was to get attribution for
the creative work that they had made and
so we were faced with a classic example
of don't ask customers what they want
figure out what they need and we
ultimately built a social network for
creative professionals that is now the
world's leading creative professional
community with over 12 million members
and you know six years later was
acquired by Adobe and so there was an
important message there which as you do
always have to be seeking empathy with
your customer you can't always
necessarily expect them to know what
you're supposed to do for them what
advice would you give to a smart driven
college student about to enter the
so-called real world what advice do you
think they should ignore so I started
with the fact that they should not hold
out for the perfect job or title don't
optimize for the slightly higher salary
you know instead focus on I think the
two things that actually matter early on
in a career number one every step in
your early career must get you
incrementally closer to it ever
genuinely interest you and the most
promising cthis success is pursuing
genuine interests and setting yourself
up for the circumstantial relationships
collaborations experiences or mistakes
of the eye that will make all the
difference in your life I like to say
that a labor of love always pays off
just not how and when you expect so you
want to set yourself up by to succeed by
taking new jobs and roles that get you
incremental II closer to the things that
are genuinely interesting to you and I
think we oftentimes fall into that
spotlight of seduction where we offered
a great opportunity that sounds great
but isn't getting us closer to interests
over the long term and that is I think
where we get off the rails of a great
career the number two is is the fact
that the greatest lessons you learn in
the beginning of a career are about
people you know how to work with people
be managed by people manage expectations
with people and lead other people and so
as such the team you choose to join and
your boss are obviously huge factors in
the value of a professional experience
early in your career and again I see so
many people optimizing for a higher
salary or a you know cooler sounding job
and not actually doing the diligence on
who they're actually
be working for or with my guest today is
Veronica Belmont you can find her on
Twitter Instagram and Facebook at
Veronica that's one hell of a handle and
learn about her work and her goings on
projects and so on at Veronica Belmont
calm Veronica is a bot obsessed product
manager in San Francisco she works for
Gro bot helping to make sure employees
get the recognition they deserve on
their teams she also helps to admin bot
wiki org and bomb-makers org a huge
community of bot creators and
enthusiasts as a writer producer and
speaker her primary goal has been to
educate audiences of all types about how
technology can enhance their lives
through the years her love of innovation
has led to advising many startups on
product communications and marketing
including Goodreads which was acquired
by Amazon about me which was acquired by
AOL daily drip sound tracking acquired
by Rhapsody milk acquired by Google whee
game acquired by tagged forge chick CEO
and more she's also a podcaster and
hosts IRL for Mozilla and sword and
laser so without further ado please
enjoy the wisdom of Veronica Belmont
how is a failure or apparent failure set
you up for later success do you have a
favorite failure of yours this one is
kind of tough to talk about my favorite
failure I guess was hosting the season 6
premiere of Game of Thrones for HBO it
was great outwardly but of course I made
the mistake of going online afterwards
and reading the comments super bad idea
I spent what should have been a really
magical evening sitting in my hotel room
sobbing into the phone with my husband
but with that feeling like really came
certainty I had been casually thinking
about making a career switch for the
previous six months or so but I was
scared of trying to do something I had
never done before professionally so
sitting there in that hotel room I
thought why am i spending my time doing
something that consistently makes me
miserable why
finally just take that chance so I did I
I stopped taking any freelance gigs I
wrapped up all of my my video contracts
and I spent all of my time learning
about product management and figuring
out where I had best fit in so overall I
mean it was a horrible night but it was
also the impetus for something
completely new and wonderful and I I
don't know if I would have been able to
really make that leap if I hadn't had
such a horrible experience that
particular night I couldn't almost see
myself just having spent the next year
waffling on that decision
so it was nice to have that finality
what are bad recommendations that you
hear in your profession or area of
expertise I think people assume that you
have to weigh all feedback on your
product you know whether that's a
podcast or an app whatever equally not
all feedback is created equal and and
not all ideas from your users are going
to be good ones taking too much stock
and feedback can really change the
vision for your own product and and
suddenly it's not gonna feel like yours
anymore what advice would you give to a
smart driven college student about to
enter the real world I've given this
advice so many times throughout my
career it's it's kind of ridiculous but
I think it still holds true for almost
any kind of career path or or project
you're working on don't wait until you
get a job to do the thing you want to be
doing for for most careers showing that
you have initiative by working on
projects related to your future hopeful
job is an amazing way to get a foot in
the door so for example if you want to
be a writer or a journalist start
keeping a blog that you update regularly
something that you can show them later
that says hey I've been writing about
this topic for the past year now I'm an
expert in this area if you want to be an
engineer or programmer create and
maintain a project on github github is
basically like the new resume anything
that you can point to on your Linkedin
that is
aiming hey I'm passionate about this
stuff is gonna work hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and will you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by athletic
greens every year
of course people look for new ways to
become healthier to take their fitness
and so on to the next level for me step
number one is having some form of
nutritional insurance that's how I would
look at it and the nutritional insurance
needs to make sure all of my basic needs
are met all the boxes checked regardless
of travel schedule missed meals and so
on there going to be times in the new
year when your diet and exercise will
get interrupted life will interrupt it
then during those times you want a
safety net I get asked all the time if
you could only use one supplement what
would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to one getting sick I
take it in the mornings to droppable
performance it just covers all my bases
if I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day
as listeners of the Tim Ferriss show you
can receive 30% off of your first order
by visiting athletic greens comm forward
slash Tim that is a great deal on one of
my favorite products and it covers my
basic search today it is part of my
routine and it leaves me with less to
worry about if for instance I have to
skip a meal or just can't get a
high-quality meal so check it out go to
athletic greens comm forward slash Tim
and learn all about this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma deck
you might remember for sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades
I will largely fix that but still
shutting off my monkey brain has never
been easy still isn't easy very often
and I found reishi which have been
fascinated by for a few years now has
been very very effective in calming
their old formula however for sig Maddox
old formula included stevia and I like
to avoid sweeteners all sweeteners for a
host of reasons and I then just ping
them and asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it too much of a headache don't
worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
studio without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water
and it mixes very very easily here are
some recommended copy that they put in
the read so I'm gonna read it and I'll
give you my take quote a warning for
those in the experimental mindset reishi
is strong and bitter in parentheses like
any great medicine so if the bitterness
is too much I recommend trying it of
honey and or nut milk such as almond
milk and quote so I'm gonna say no you
should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter and
maybe should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
youngins when they say allowing sugar
cool which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on not saying
that's the case here but I've tested
this ratio lecture on family members on
friends everybody has liked it it's a
little bit earthy it's not that hard so
I would just say suck it up and no don't
put in honey or a nut milk or any of
that [ __ ] just drink the goddamn tea
it's delicious I think alright if you
like to air that kind of stuff that type
of tea you're gonna dig it so just try
it okay back to then my read if you'd
like to naturally improve your sleep
both on set and quality I think it
naturally
you might just enjoy this ratio lecture
without any sweeteners it has organic
reishi extract organic fueled myth
extract organic rosehips extract organic
Tulsi extract and that's it no fancy
stuff no artificial whatchamacallit
anything so check it out go to four
sigma deck comport size Ferriss and get
20% off this special batch I don't know
if they're gonna be making much more of
this since it was made specifically for
you guys so do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be open to
experimenting with me to create products
for you guys specifically check it out
for sig Matic that's fo you are SI g ma
TI c calm /if eros f e RR ISS and get
20% off the special batch and you must
use
is the code ferrous to receive a
discount FBR Riss so again go to for sig
Matic compote slash Paris and then use
code ferrous for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
[Applause]